ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف الناطق الرسمي باسم
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين محمد عبد
السلام مرحبا بك سيد محمد كيف تابعتم
اعلان وزير الدفاع الامريكي عن تشكيل
تحالف دولي لمواجهه ما تقومون به في البحر
الاحمر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم التحالف او
التجمع الذي اعلن عنه الامريكي من وسط تل
ابيب هو في الواقع ياتي لحمايه اسرائيل
وياتي لحمايه ايضا البضائع المتجهه الى
اسرائيل لاعطائها مزيدا من الوقت
للاستمرار في القتل وارتكاب المجازر
البشعه بحق الشعب الفلسطيني بالنسبه لهذا
الموقف من الناحيه العمليه هو لن يؤثر على
عملياتنا في البحر الاحمر ولا يمكن ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تعطي
اسرائيل مزيدا من الوقت لارتكاب المجاز
وهي من تقف
صدا مانعا لامام اي قراء يمكن ان يؤدي الى
وقف اطلاق النار في غزه في غزه وكذلك لا
يوجد اي مساهمه حقيقيه او فاعله في ادخال
المساعدات الى ابناء قطاع غزه ولهذا نحن
نعتقد او نعتبر ان الذي جاء من تلبيب هو
اعلان من اجل حمايه اسرائيل وليس من اجل
حمايه الملاحه الدوليه لقد اكدنا مرارا ان
البحر الا العربي المياه نعم انتم تقولون
ان هذا التحالف لن يؤثر على عملياتكم ول
لكن هذا
التحالف يتوعد باسقاط جميع الصواريخ
والمسيرات التي تقومون باطلاقها قبل ان
تصل الى
اهدافها هم يقومون باسقاطه من قبل هناك
فرقاطات فرنسيه وبريطانيه وامريكيه من
اليوم الاول هذا ليس جديد هم موجودين في
الضفه الاخرى في الضفه الاخرى بال
المحاذيه للبحر الاحمر ويمارسون طيران
استطلاع ويستهدفون طائرات مسيره ويقومون
باسقاطه نعم هذه هي المعركه العسكريه لكن
انه سيكون هناك تطور اخر لا يمكن ان يكون
ولا يستطيعون فعل ذلك الا اذا اجحم انفسهم
في عمليات مباشره ضد اليمن وهذا ما سيوسع
المعركه ويجعلها حربا اقليميه ودوليه لا
يتوقعون ايضا الاثار الكارثيه التي قد
تنعكس في حال اقدم على مثل ذلك الان
العديد من شركات النقل اعلنت انها لن
تعتمد الابحار في البحر الاحمر وعبر باب
المندب بشكل كلي كيف تبعت
هذه
الاعلانات نحن تواصلنا مع مثل هذه الشركات
ومع الدول الاخرى المرتبطه بها واكد انه
لا داعي لان يكون هناك توجه لايقاف
الملاحه في البحر العربي والبحر الاحمر
وان هذه محاوله للضغط الامريكي وبعض الدول
الغربيه لان يكون هناك موقف من الدول
العربيه المطله على البحر الاحمر ل
المشاركه في هذا التحالف الذي يراد منه
حمايه اسرائيل وليس حمايه الملا الملاحه
الدوليه ولهذا نحن نشيد ببعض الشركات التي
اعلنت ايقاف الملاحه الى موانئ اسرائيل
باعتباره باعتباره الخيار الصحيح والسليم
باعتبار ان عملياتنا نحن انما تستهدف من
يتجه الى اسرائيل وبدليل ان هناك مئات من
السفن تمر ربما بشكل يومي من مضيق باب
المندب لا يمسها اي اذى وانما الذي يستهدف
هو السفن المتجهه الى اسرائيل فقط ولهذا
نحن نطالب ونؤكد و من خلال تواصلا تنا
الدبلوماسيه مع بقيه الدول ومع الشركات
الاخرى بان البحر الاحمر امن وانهم
بامكانهم المرور سيد محمد عندما تقوم كبرى
شركات النقل بالاعلان انها لن تعتمد هذه
الطريق البحريه في ابحارها الا تخشون ان
يبدا ذلك بالتاثير على دول
المنطقه شانهم في الاخير يجب ان يتحرك
الضغط على اسرائيل لايقاف عدوانها وفك
حصارها على قطاع غزه والدول الاخرى
الموجوده في المنطقه يجب ان تتجه الاتجاه
الصحيح بالضغط على اسرائيل وامريكا لايقاف
هذا الصلف هل وصل الحال ان ان تدلل
اسرائيل الى هذا المستوى بانه اي طرف يقوم
بمواجهه عدوانها وصفها يواجه هو يعني
المطلوب من اليمن ان ان يتوقف عن مضايقه
اسرائيل كي نسمح لها بالاستمرار بقتل
فلسطين وبقتل ابنائها وتدميرها وقتل
اطفالها ونسائها هل هذا هو المعقول نحن لا
نتوقع ان تقف دوله واحده تمتلك جزء من
المروءه والدره دره مسؤوليه اخلاقيه
وانسانيه لتقف الى جانب اسرائيل لتعطيها
هذهه الجائزه الكبرى حتى لا تضايق من قبل
اي طرف وهي تمارس ابشع انواع المجازر في
هذا القرن ولهذا نحن نعتقد ان الدول
الاخرى حتى الان موقفها جيد خاصه المطله
على البحر الاحمر ونتمنى ان تستمر في هذا
الموقف الايجابي اما نحن لا يمكن ان نتوقف
ومن عليه ان ان يتوجه اليه اللوم والضغط
هي اسرائيل وامريكا ل هذا العدوان بعتبار
مطلبنا انساني نحن عندما نطالب بوقف الحرب
على قطاع غزه وفك الحصار هذا موقف انساني
يقف الى جانبه اغلب دول العالم واغلب شعوب
المنطقه فلماذا يتجه الينا الموقف وموقفنا
هو رده فعل فقط تجاه ما يت اخواننا
وابنائنا في فلسطين اعتقد ان من يجب ان
يتوجه اللوم الضغط عليه امريكا وحلفا سيد
محمد هل يمكن ان تضعنا في صوره اخر تطورات
الجهود الدبلوماسيه الجاريه معكم عبر
سلطنه عمان
نعم هناك تواصل عبر الاشقاء في سلطنه عمان
خاصه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فيما
له علاقه بمجريات العمليات العسكريه في
البحر الاحمر ونحن اكدنا على موقفنا ان
العمليات الاخيره التي تمت هي من اجل
السماح بادخال الغذاء والدواء الى فلسطين
والسماح بادخال المساعدات بشكل كاف وواف
حتى نتبين من ابناء فلسطين ان المساعدات
بدات تدخلهم في قطاع غزه في شمالها وجنوب
بها وهذا هو موقفنا الذي نقلناه عبر
الاخوه في سلطنه عمان الى الامريكيين
النقاشات مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه وموقفنا
هو ما ما نؤكد عليه دائما وهو انه يجب
ادخال المساعدات بشكل كامل واننا لن نسمح
لاي شركه ملاحه تتحرك عبر البحر الاحمر
الى موانئ اسرائيل وقطاع غزه محاصر لا
يمكن ان نقبل ولا يمكن ان تتوقف العمليات
حتى تحقيق هذا المبدا الانساني اما السفن
الاسرائيليه او المشارك فيها اسرائيليون
لن لن يتوقف استهدافها ابدا حتى يتوقف
العدوان كذلك العمليات الصاروخيه والطيران
المسير وحتى في العمليات الانسانيه ستكون
مراقبه وبحسب ما يفيدنا اخواننا في فلسطين
اذا وجدوا ان الحصار انتهى وان المساعدات
بدات تدخل بشكل سلس نحن ممكن ان نقوم بخفض
التصعيد ما عدا ذلك لا نستطيع ان نبادر
الى اي خطوه اخرى النقاش عبر الاشقاء في
سلطنه عمان ومتواصل حتى هذه اللحظه لم نصل
بعد الى رؤيه واضحه في ه هذا الاتجاه كما
ان تواصلنا مع الاخوه الفلسطينيين ووضعهم
في صوره مفاوضاتنا مع المجتمع الدولي ايضا
مستمره وقائمه طيب اليوم هيئه التجاره
البريطانيه اعلنت انها تلقت بلاغا بشان
حادثه جديده ضد سفينه قباله
جيبوتي هل انتم على بينه بهذا الامر نعم
ستستمر العمليات البحريه على قدم وساج
ربما لا تمر 12 ساعه دون ان تكون هناك
عمليه وتقوم القوات البحريه بالتحقق بعبر
اكثر من وسيله امنيه ومخابرات للتحقق من
السفن وهويات وشركائها وايضا المشاركون
فيها والعمليات ستستمر حتى نصل الى ايقاف
حقيقي للعدوان على قطاع غزه وفك الحصار
عليها وكذلك ايقاف الهمجيه في الضفه
الغربيه وهذا موقف معلن وتحمل اليمن هذا
العبء الاخلاقي من واقع انساني وديني
ومبدئي و ونحن ندرك ما نفعل وندرك عواقب
ما نقوم به وما نقوم هو نصره لاخواننا
المظلومين ونداءاتهم التي تصل الى قلوبنا
والى اسماعنا في مواجهه هذا الصلف
الاسرائيلي نحن نعتقد ان الموقف الذي يقوم
به اليمن هو اقل واجب يمكن ان
نقمه
فلين امتنا العربيه والاسلاميه والانسانيه
ان تقف الى جانبنا ايضا في مواجهه الصلف
الاسرائيلي المتوحش طيب سيد محمد لكن
عندما تقوم كبرى شات النقل بوقف الملاحه
كليا في هذه الطريق البحريه هي يعني ربما
غير واثقه من ان السفن التي يجري فقط
استهدافها هي السفن المتجهه والتي لها
علاقه باسرائيل
هذا كلام صحيح وقد حصل من خلال نقاشاتنا
مع المجتمع الدولي نحن قد يكون هناك مخاوف
لدى بعض الشركات من ان العمليات قد تكون
يحصل فيها اخطاء نحن على تواصل مع هذه
الشركات ونطلب منهم اولا فتح معرفات
التواصل البحريه المعروفه للنداءات
والاستجابه للنداءات اليمنيه والتاكيد عن
هويه السفينه والاجابه عن بعض الاستفسارات
اضافه الى ذلك قد يحصل خطا غير مقصود هذا
غير مستبعد ولا نعتقد انه هو يحصل في كل
الحروب لكن حتى الان العمليات دقيقه بنسبه
95% بدليل انه لم تاتي الينا شركه لتدعي
او لتنفي ان ليس لها علاقه باسرائيل على
الاطلاق حتى هذه اللحظه ونقدم ما لدينا من
ادله ومعلومات ونطالب الدول الاخرى بان
تقدم او الشركات ان تفتح المعرفات في
البحر وان تجيب انها ليس لها علاقه
باسرائيل او غير ذاهبه الى الى موانئ
اسرائيل وللعلم اسرائيل اعتمد التمويه من
هذه الفتره الاخيره وحاول ان يذهب الى
موانئ اخرى كمحطات للترانزيت وان يعمل عبر
شركات اخرى والقوات اليمنيه تحاول ان
تكتشف هذه اللاعيب محمد طيب انتم تقولون
ان هذه العمليات مستمره حتى يتم ادخال
الغذاء والدواء الى قطاع غزه ويرفع الحصار
ماذا لو لم يحدث هذا الامر
قريبا اذا لم يحدث هذا الامر قريبا
العمليات اليمنيه ستظل وربما بوتيره اعلى
نحن هذا الموقف اتخذناه بتاييد شعبي كبير
جدا وربما لا يختلف عليه اثنان في اليمن
على ان هذا الموقف الاخلاقي والانساني
الذي يقوم به اليمن والذي استطاع في هذه
الظروف ان يقوم به ان يستمر فيه فاذا لم
يقوموا بفك الحصار ولا ادخال المساعدات
وقف اليمن سيستمر بل وسيتصدى
بكل ما نستطيع بكل ما نستطيع من الوسائل
المتاحه والممكن شكرا جزيلا لك المتحدث
باسم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين